-Hi, Busy, how are you?
-Hi, Seth. I'm good.
How are you?
-Good. It is wonderful
to see you, as always.
And I know your entire family
of four
celebrated quarantine birthdays.
-We did.
-And I imagine it's harder
for the kids than the adults,
but you did something really
lovely for your daughter Birdie.
-Well, I don't know.
There's a lot --
Your kids are a little bit
younger, but here in L.A.,
parents have been organizing
these, like, drive-by birthdays,
parades, and things.
And like, I did not have it
together to do that.
So I sent out an e-mail
asking for some of her friends
and our family to send videos.
Like, I thought that was cute.
But to be honest with you,
the people that she spent
the most time with over
quarantine are the actors
from "Community"
and "Brooklyn Nine-Nine"
because she watched both of
those shows pretty much nonstop.
So, I happen to, like,
know some of those actors.
So I texted Gillian Jacobs,
who's like a good friend of mine
and, like, comes to our house
and Birdie knows her.
So, when Gillian came up on the
video, I think Birdie was like,
"Oh, it's just
my mom's friends."
And then Danny Pudi
sent a video,
and, like, Birdie lost her mind.
And then it was, like,
from "Brooklyn Nine-Nine."
She just --
The tears and the screaming,
it was everything
that I truly wanted it to be.
I mean, it was incredible.
-We have a video.
We're just going to show
a few seconds of it.
But as a parent, I mean, this is
really you hitting the jackpot.
I really just want
to tip my cap.
-Okay, can I just tell you
that she's a kid
who's been so unimpressed
with me and my career.
Like, her entire life has just
been like, "Yeah, whatever.
You're on television.
Fine, okay? Hi, Courteney Cox."
You know, like, so unimpressed.
And this was one of my --
I think this is, like,
my top parenting moment
of the last five years.
I felt like I finally nailed it.
And I also put the call out
so wide, thinking that, like,
if I only got Gillian
to send a video,
it would be totally nice
and fine,
but everyone sent videos,
including her two favorite
YouTubers from England
who I just, like,
DM'd on Twitter.
I mean, it was wild.
So, yeah, watch her reaction
when it changes.
It's crazy.
-Hey!
-[ Screaming in excitement ]
-Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
How you doing, big girl?
-Whoa! What?!
Oh-ho-ho-ho!
-Truly amazing.
Also, incredibly genuine
from her.
This is not --
You know, I don't think anybody
could pretend
to be that excited.
Now, you have asked Birdie
to do a little acting.
You asked her to be
in a music video you directed.
-Yes.
-Was she hard to convince?
-Yeah. I mean,
she's not particularly --
she's very, like -- she's just
into what she's into, man,
and, like, if it's not something
she's interested in,
you can forget it.
I think that's probably,
like, most kids.
But some kids are a little bit
maybe more polite, or, like,
they'll, like --
You know what I mean?
Or they'll -- like, even just
to show that little clip,
I went and asked her,
and I said,
"You know who Seth Meyers is?"
And she's like, "Yeah, I guess."
And then I was like, "Well,
you know Josh." I was like,
"You know he's Josh's brother
and he's got a late-night show.
Can I show that clip?"
And she's like,
"Yeah, I guess for him.
Yeah, that's fine."
Like, you know?
[ Laughs ]
So, anyway,
we've been in quarantine.
This singer-songwriter
lives in our guest house.
And so, she is by herself --
I mean, so,
she's quarantined with us.
And her EP came out yesterday --
or not her EP,
but her new song off her
upcoming EP came out yesterday,
and she was like, "My label
really wants me to make a video,
but what am I going to do?"
And I was like,
"Well, lucky for you,
we have iPhones and work in
the film industry."
So we came up with this concept
for the video,
and I really just loved the idea
of having Birdie and her little
friend that were staying with us
as this protagonists
in the video,
and having Sarah Beth Tomberlin
is her name as a singer
sort of following them,
and it turned out so well.
-It really did. It's so much fun
to watch and listen to.
-Thanks.
Yeah, I was really proud of it.
Marc edited it on his
Final Cut Pro on his computer.
I think the label, like, at
first, her record label's like,
"Yeah, I guess the people you
live with can make this video."
And then they were really
excited when it turned out
the way that it did,
and so were we.
So, yeah, check that out,
I guess.
-You also have a podcast.
And, Busy, you have often noted
and addressed the fact
that you love to talk.
This seemed like a natural
conclusion of your talents
as someone who is naturally --
-Well, Seth, I thought
it was going to be
a late-night talk show
was going to be the natural...
-[ Laughing ] I know.
-But you know what?
A podcast, great.
No, I -- Yeah. I had --
After "Busy Tonight" ended,
Caissie St. Onge, who's my --
who was my show runner
on that show, and I --
basically, we're going in
a whole new direction
and we had this whole project
we were putting together.
And we sold the podcast as
kind of like a part of that,
and we were going to take people
on the journey,
kind of like "StartUp."
I don't know if you ever
listened to that podcast.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
So, we had recorded
hours and hours of stuff,
starting in, like, December.
And the podcast was
supposed to come out
I think the beginning of May.
And then, obviously,
the world changed,
and our project was, like,
put on hold indefinitely.
And I just was like,
"Well, what do we do now?"
And I took a minute.
I had to, like, figure out
how to homeschool my kids
and do all that stuff.
And then we decided to,
like, lean into the pivot,
and we asked Shantira Jackson,
who was one of my writers
and performers on "Busy Tonight"
to come join us,
and we're talking to people
about pivots that they've taken
in their own lives
and how they worked out
or led them to the place
where they needed to be.
And honestly, I feel like
at this moment right now,
we all could benefit from
hearing the stories of people
who, in their darkest hours
thought,
"Well, I don't even know
how I'm going to move forward,"
somehow figured it out,
took the pivot,
and, like, ended up
in a better place
because we're all being
asked to do that, you know.
-Yeah, and it's really
a perfect example
that the podcast is
a version of that, right?
That you had
this different podcast,
and then you ended up
with this one.
So it's also -- it's nice, both
that you talk to guests about it
and that you serve as
a perfect example of it.
So, congratulations
on the podcast.
-Thanks.
-Hopefully, I will see you and
your lovely family again soon.
-I've probably seen your brother
'cause I've actually seen him
on the street with his mask on,
walking his dog.
So, I probably have seen your
family more than, you know --
-More than I have.
I would say with masks
and this hair, I could fully
pull off a Josh right now.
-100%.
[ Laughter ]
I really do think --
I do think, Seth,
that you should film
your post-COVID haircut.
-Yeah, I will.
We'll put that out
for the world.
-I want to see it.
Just some online content.
You know what I mean?
-Yeah, you're right.
You're right.
I should listen to you on that.
I should pivot -- I'm gonna
pivot into some online content.
-That's exactly
what you should do.
Alright, well, I mean, it's
so good to talk to you, always.
-Alright, I'll see you soon.
Thanks, Busy.
-I will.
Tell everybody I said hi.